[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK MARTIN: Good
morning, everybody.
I'm Nick Martin.
I'm head of Google's Cloud
business for retail in the UK.
Well done for making
it here 9:00 AM
on the final day of our
Google NEXT Conference.
We recognize that we had
some stiff competition
from the party last night and
also, the keynote that's taking
place at the moment,
so a big well done.
And thank you for
choosing this session
to spend some time
with us this morning.
I'd like to start the
session with an insight
into retailers' most
important asset--
the shopper.
Shoppers today are curious,
demanding, and impatient.
Shoppers have more touch
points with your business
than ever before.
They visit your website.
They use your app.
They come to your
physical store,
call to your customer
service line,
join your loyalty program,
watch your YouTube videos,
stop by your Facebook page,
subscribe to your email, lists,
and more.
They also see your ads; search,
social, video, TV, radio,
print, and out of home.
So these interactions
produce a wealth
of information
about your customers
and what they want
from your business.
Good news for business?
Well, not necessarily,
if that information
is not used effectively.
In fact, according to a
joint study Google conducted
with Greenberg, at
least 62% of people
expect brands to use
their purchase history
to provide them with
personalized experiences.
Yet, only 42% think most
brands currently do.
So why is that?
Is it an impossible
task to deliver
relevant, personalized
experiences at every touch
point?
What are the reasons
that may prevent this?
Typically, an
organization's data
is spread across many places;
ad campaigns, CRM systems,
customer service blogs,
website/app analytics, loyalty
programs, and many, many more.
So this means it can be
very, very difficult to get
a single view of each customer.
So it's no surprise that
almost 60% of marketers,
according to Forrester,
say that it remains
difficult to give stakeholders
in different business functions
access to data and the
insights that they need.
And without it, how can they
create truly personalized
experiences?
But to deliver that
kind of experience
that your customer now
expects, organizations
need to take a very
different approach.
The key thing is you need
to have all of your data--
not just some of your data--
in one place, structured
and unstructured,
all different types.
And when it's in one place, then
you're in a position to unlock
the most valuable
insights it provides.
Cloud Solutions enable you
to break down data silos
and organize your data
such that you can better
analyze and activate it
to gain better insights
and drive better and
more predictive outcomes.
We speak with many
organizations who are actively
working to incorporate
artificial intelligence
and machine learning into
their data analytics strategy.
Yet, the vast majority
of those organizations
are at the very earliest
stage of AI initiative.
According to the Gartner
survey, the CIO survey
last year, it's reckoned
that only 4% of CIOs
currently have AI under way
within the organization.
Yet, this is set
to change rapidly
over the next two
to three years.
In fact, it's reckoned by 2020,
more than 85% of organizations
will have AI
programs under pilot
or in an operational mode.
So why is that?
Well, to adopt AI, customers
face many, many challenges.
Technology-- the scale needed
to handle AI is massive.
From an operational
perspective, you
need to have the right expertise
in place, the right people.
But very few organizations
have those people--
they're a scarce breed--
and tooling, which, to date,
has been very narrow in terms
of the options that it
provides and requiring
much specialization.
So realistically,
AI has only been
in the hands of very few
people, very few organizations
in the last few decades.
And it's those who've had
access to deep computational
resources, training, and
specialized expertise
in machine learning,
organizations
that are technology-oriented.
So you need to
embrace new approaches
and adopt technologies like
artificial intelligence,
but doing that is a huge
operational challenge.
This is where Google
Cloud comes in.
Google Cloud is Google's
public cloud computing business
and brings a variety of
products and services
to provide you with AI at scale.
So why choose Google for AI?
Well, we provide that massive
scale, the same computing power
that powers Google
Search, Gmail, Maps,
Android, and many others which
have over a billion users
today.
We provide high performance,
a global infrastructure
as a service, leveraging
Google's technology
and servers, processes,
and private fiber network,
and quality of technology with
a range of innovations Google
has developed for data
management, analytics,
and artificial intelligence.
And bringing together
customization for a Cloud AI
solution with an approach we
take to do advance solution
labs where we will
develop innovation
with you, our
professional services
capability, and the extensive
range of business partners
that Google has is how
we bring this to you
to provide that AI capability
in your organization
and improve your productivity.
We provide a spectrum of
AI machine learning tools.
And you would have heard some
of these being further announced
during this conference.
And this is enabling you to
leverage your organization's
capabilities and skill sets, and
also your big asset in client.
On one end, we have pre-trained
out-of-the-box models
for companies that don't really
have that expertise in-house.
And you can use
pre-trained models
like Vision API, Video API,
Video Analysis, Natural
Language API, or Translation API
to deliver certain experiences
to your customer.
On the other end
of the scale, you
have Google's market
leading open source machine
learning engine
TensorFlow, which
lets your data scientists
build their own models to solve
customer challenges
within your business.
And in the middle, we
offer manage services
like Cloud ML that brings
the best of both worlds
together so you can customize
models for specific use,
but use our manage
services to test,
train, and scale your
models in the Cloud.
Now, enough for me.
What you're really here for is
to hear a real customer who's
been doing this.
So to bring it all to
life, I'm absolutely
delighted to introduce and
welcome on to the stage
Jonty Angel, who is
head of Ocado Technology
and a good friend
of Google Cloud.
Jonty.
[APPLAUSE]
JONTY ANGEL: Thank you.
Hello.
NICK MARTIN: So, Jonty,
to kick things off--
JONTY ANGEL: Yes.
NICK MARTIN: --can you
explain the Ocado business
model and a little bit
about Ocado for us?
JONTY ANGEL: Sure.
So should I take that?
Thank you.
Cool.
So firstly, thank you
for having me here.
It's always great
to be in San Fran.
The weather's not unbelievable.
I came in from London where
it's about 36 degrees and heat
waves.
However, it is nice to be here
and nice to be with everyone.
Thank you also, for
coming in this morning.
I know after the
party last night,
probably not easy to wake up
and come to the 9:00 AM session.
And thanks, Nick, for
that introduction.
So to answer your
question, what is Ocado?
And what businesses
are in Ocado?
So quickly, by a show of
hands, who has heard of Ocado
or interacted with Ocado?
OK, Good.
So that means my colleagues
who have been speaking also
at some other sessions
have done a good job,
because there's some hands up.
Who's used Ocado before?
So very few hands.
So basically, Ocado,
at a high level,
is really a fusion
of two businesses.
On the one side, we
have a retail business,
which, if you've
lived in the UK,
or you've actually used the
service, or been into London
and seen some of
the vans, you'll
know that we run an online
grocery supermarket where
we take orders in.
And through a series of
supply chain activities,
we then deliver an order
to people's houses.
And actually, we go
further than that.
We go into the kitchen and
deliver it into the kitchen.
So it's a great
end-to-end service
where you can have your
groceries delivered
in a one hour time slot.
That's our retail
side of the business.
And depending that we have
a technology business, which
actually is only really
come to light over
the last few years
in the public eye,
the technology business focuses
on building the platform
that powers that
retail business.
So things that are
important are all
of the learnings
that are happening
in the retail business, all
of the specific customer
requirements, and then this
real-time feedback loop
that we get from our retail
customers interacting
with the Ocado brand.
So what you have here
is this unique fusion
of two businesses with
an amazing feedback
loop that's real-time.
So on the one side,
we're learning
from customers, because we
have an online supermarket.
And on the other side,
we're building technology
to support that service.
So then, who is Ocado?
So Ocado is the world's largest
dedicated online grocery
retailer.
We have over 600,000
active shoppers.
We have a range of
over 50,000 SKUs
across our four
automated warehouses.
And we pick around a quarter
of a million orders per week.
So for an online-only
business with no stores,
that's quite big.
Just to give you
an understanding
of the number of orders,
this is a picture
which was taken actually in
San Francisco on an ad for Sony
BRAVIA.
They released a whole lot of
bouncing balls into the street.
And actually, they
released 250,000 balls,
so just to give you perspective
on the kind of number
of orders we're doing in a
week through our automated
facilities.
So then, taking the
lens and looking
through that second business,
which is our technology
business, the question is, what
is the Ocado Smart Platform?
So this is our modular and
scalable software and hardware
platform, designed to put
the world's largest retailers
online.
So we currently
have some partners,
which you would have
seen in the press
releases over the
last year or so,
who have engaged
in this platform.
And what the platform
aids to do is
to deliver a full
end-to-end service
for your retail business.
So there are three key
activities over here
which we focus on within
our end-to-end platform.
The first activity
is that of shopping.
So we create an
interface where customers
can come to a website,
and engage with the site,
and shop, and add favorites,
et cetera, et cetera,
and build a basket.
Once that's complete, we then
have to fulfill that order.
So we have to pick it.
And we have our
automated facilities.
And we also have an
in-store picking system.
And then once that order
is picked and fulfilled,
we then need to deliver
it to the customer.
So the third part is delivery.
And that's where we
load up our vans.
And using proprietary routing
systems and algorithms,
we deliver the groceries to our
users, either in their homes
or via click and
collect-type portals.
So an image, which, from
a product perspective,
is a lot easier to get your head
around what the platform is,
would be to try dividing
into these triangles, where,
as I mentioned, you
have the shopping
experience in the top half
of the triangles, which
is responsible for the
ecommerce activities.
You then have our fulfillment
triangle, effectively,
or module, which is responsible
for fulfilling those orders.
And then you have
our delivery module,
which is responsible for
sending them to clients.
And they are all held
together with a core, which
is responsible for
things like the basket
pricing engines or the specific
order management systems,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So the platform is really
modular and scalable.
But also, what this
slide is highlighting is
I've listed their
current capabilities are
around the things
that you traditionally
find in one of these internet
supply chain systems.
I've also highlighted
future opportunity examples.
So the platform's being
built in a way where
we can innovate and really
stay on the bleeding edge.
So for example, IoT,
robotics, autonomous vehicles,
those are all areas we're
extremely interested in
and want to enable our
platform to easily engage in.
NICK MARTIN: So, Jonty, you
mentioned technology platform.
Can you share further
insights into those platforms,
the department, and some of the
machine learning innovations
that you've implemented at
Ocado to support your customers?
JONTY ANGEL: Yes, I can.
So in order to
answer that question,
I would first, like
to just give you
quite a high level overview of
what the technology division is
at Ocado.
So as I said, we're the tale
of these two businesses,
the retail and the technology.
And what we've established is
it's more than just a division,
actually.
It's almost like a
company on it's own,
a business on its own.
We have Ocado Technology.
And that's responsible
for building the software
that powers Ocado.
So we have over 1,000 people
working in Ocado Technology.
And more than half
of those people
are computer scientists,
engineers, data specialists,
and machine learning
specialists.
So we've invested in people
who have these skills
and can build up the
side of our business.
We also have European
offices where
we have developers in Poland.
We have two offices
there, actually,
in Krakow and Wroclaw.
And we have an
office in Barcelona.
And then we also have an
office in Sofia in Bulgaria.
So these offices are
first technology offices,
building the platform.
And the bulk of our
development does also
happen in Hatfield, in the UK.
Behind Ocado Technology,
there are really
three core principles
that enable
us to build the
seamless experience
and platform for our customers.
That is intuitive,
efficient, and convenient.
So what I mean by
intuitive is we make sure
that our web shop experience
or our shopping experience
is very easy to use.
So anything we build
has to be easy to use.
It has to be immediately
accessible by our customers.
Efficient.
So because we need to do
things fast and a lot of things
at scale, like picking orders,
packing them, delivering them,
sorting them, all kinds of
these operational processes,
along the whole end-to-end,
we need to be efficient.
So we effectively need
to be efficient at scale.
And I've got a video
actually, where
I'll show you one of
our latest warehouses
and how we are building
robots to help us be
more automated and efficient.
And then, convenient.
Well, I have a picture of
one of our delivery drivers.
And what this really
means is we need
to build software and
applications that are not
just great, and fast, and
out there in the market,
and quickly in the hands of
our customers, and innovative.
They need to be convenient,
easy to use, easy
to understand by our employees.
So when that delivery
driver gets to the door,
the first thing that
they're thinking of
is to offer a great
experience to the user
and not to be hung
up on the technology.
So the technology
needs to work for them,
to allow them to do their job.
And that's one of
our principles,
is we need to empower our
people to be able to easily use
the technology.
Now, to achieve
those principles,
you have to invest
in a lot of back end
skills, a lot of capabilities.
And what Ocado has
done over the years--
actually, since the start--
has invested in
these departments.
We have a lot of
people who are working
on automation and robotics.
We have specialists in
machine learning, mobile app
development, routing
systems, data science, Cloud,
vision systems, simulation.
I mean, if you walk around
one of our warehouses,
you'll see all these things
interacting with each other
and giving you an insight that
this is a technology business
that you're in the heart of.
Just to talk to
Nick's point, for us,
we need to invest heavily in
skills like machine learning
and basically how to use Cloud
technologies, which prompts
us to collaborate further
with companies like Google,
because that investment
is crucial to us taking
the next step, which
is keeping innovative,
keeping on the bleeding edge,
offering those new systems,
building those intelligent
personalized experiences.
And that's where we want to be.
So as a business,
we've incorporated
this in our culture.
And that's how we're
moving forward.
So I've got a video
here just to show you
one of the areas of
the platform, which I
think is extremely impressive.
It's basically, once an order
is ready to be delivered,
we have our routing
system that takes over
to understand where orders
need to be dropped off
and in what order and
the particular vans
that will take them there.
So you can see this here is a
simulation based on real data,
actually.
And it's just been sped
up across an entire day.
What you can see is
every little pin drop
is actually a completed order.
So as an order
gets delivered, you
can see that it lights
up like a little drop.
We're probably, in the
simulation, around midday
or 1:00 PM where London
gets a bit nuclear,
so you can see the
activity over there.
And then the other big
patches of activity
are around our automated
fulfillment centers,
you can actually
see Dawdon, where
we have a big center there.
Andover, we have another one.
So in order to do
this, we have to invest
in algorithms that
can basically give us
the most efficient routing
around our geography
to deliver those orders.
And you can go to
that link over there
to find out more about our
specific routing systems.
The second video that
I want to show you
is of our latest technology
in our warehouses.
Oops.
Let me go back.
I think I need to click that.
Oh.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is Andover
Performance Center.
Oop.
And Andover is
southwest of London.
And as you can see
here, this is a view
from the top of a grid
or a hive structure,
which is a highly
dense storage system.
And what you're doing is
you're looking over the grid.
And imagine looking at the
size of a football pitch
where literally you
have over 1,000 robots
moving on top of this grid,
doing different activities.
So some of the activities
that the robots do
is, when products are brought
into the hive from suppliers,
there's robot activity which
basically unpacks and places
them in the grid.
Other activities are
bringing products
to areas of the grid where
we have a picking aisle.
So we actually, within the
grid, have a picking tunnel.
And we have people who
are placing products
into different baskets
and different assortments.
And another function
of the bots,
which is actually what I
think is the most intelligent,
is, at the end of every
shift, the bots run
a specific algorithm
or set of algorithms
that allow them to
do housekeeping,
which is they prepare the grid
for the next set of orders.
So effectively
what happens is we
can make sure that the
grid is always stocked
with the orders in
the right places
to efficiently fulfill the
next set of deliveries.
So I hope you can get
an idea of the size.
And those are charging stations
at the back, basically,
which the bots go off to.
NICK MARTIN: Pretty impressive.
I've actually had the
pleasure of visiting that DC.
And I would have
to say, if you ever
get the opportunity
to go and visit,
it's the most impressive
setup and a lot of fun.
So, Jonty, can you take
us-- how are we doing?
Can you take us onto how
machine learning is directly
providing your customers
with a better buying
experience and service?
JONTY ANGEL: Yes.
So just first, to introduce what
is a benefit for our customers,
I would like to share the
three core areas that we look
every day to improve
on is, number one,
we need to make sure that
deliveries are on time.
It's more important to
get a delivery on time
than anything, because
that's the expectation
of the customer.
The second is great shelf life.
So we need to make sure that all
our products have a great shelf
life so that they are in the
life of before they expire.
And actually, Ocado has
a life promise in that.
And then almost
no substitutions.
So that means when
you place an order,
you want those products
that you ordered.
You don't want to see a
whole list of other products
which we just threw in there.
So you want the
products you ordered.
So our supply chain
systems need to be
efficient and accurate to
ensure that the right stock is
in the right warehouse.
If I go on to the benefits
to retailers, well,
if we aren't focusing on
building the technology,
then that takes a lot
of the risk off them,
and they can effectively focus
on running their business.
So that gives us an
opportunity to develop
more intelligent systems for
the retailer to benefit from.
So for example, one of
the benefits is low waste.
And that's because, in
our customer journey,
we have different mechanisms
of offering products
throughout the
journey that ensure
that maybe those products
that were going to be wasted
can be re-offered within
the customer journey.
There's another one called
know your customer--
which I'll talk about
a little bit later--
which is around
customization, where we do
use machine learning to
get a better understanding
of the needs of our customer
based on previous orders
so that we can deliver a
more personalized experience.
And then, there's a couple
of other ones over here
which add to the overall
benefit that a retailer gets
from using our platform.
So more specifically,
to answer your question,
the two areas that
I'll briefly highlight
where we've used machine
learning to positively impact
our customer experience
and our platform
has been in fraud detection
and in customization.
So I have a little
quote up here which
shares the motivation of why we
wanted to use machine learning
for fraud detection.
And it was really
all about, how can
we have speed and adaptability?
So we know that
if we were humans
looking at fraudulent
activity and trying
to make assessments and
predictions, what would happen
is that the fraudsters
would effectively
change the way that
they operate in a way
where we would need to be
really, really quick to keep up
with them.
So what we felt is that
this is a perfect use
case for machine learning,
where we could just
let a machine do that.
And if we have enough
data in the background
to power that
engine, the machines
would become more intelligent
and would understand how
to spot fraudulent behavior.
Actually, my colleagues
spoke a bit more about this
in another session.
I think it was yesterday.
And there's a video which
explains more technically
what we're doing there.
But at a high level, the
data sets that we're using
are things like past orders,
previous cases of fraud,
past deliveries, the cost
of baskets, order items.
So you know that if
someone is effectively,
every morning at 9:00
AM, buying X amounts of--
I don't know-- alcohol
and they are just
being placed in these
random delivery spots,
you can assume it's
fraudulent activity.
But the powerful thing is taking
all these data sets together,
you get new trends
and you get new ideas.
And you can actually,
for the first time,
stay ahead of the
fraudulent activity.
With fraud, what's interesting
is, in our customer journey,
actually, we do
our fraud detection
at the front end of
that customer journey.
So effectively, when you enter
the site to start shopping,
we are already doing
the fraud checks
and starting to assess
fraudulent activity.
And that's because
we want to make
sure that anything that happens
after that is not fraudulent.
Some of the tools
that we use are we
really try use the whole
stack of Google Cloud.
So we use the ML Engine,
BigQuery, Cloud Storage,
and TensorFlow.
And this is a really,
really big project
right now within our business.
This is another
diagram which just
gives that whole data flow.
So the last section
is customization.
So if, again, you look at the
end-to-end customer journey
where you start an order,
you start doing your shopping
and preparing your
order, and then you
go through to
completing your order,
to checkout, what we
found is that the real way
to impact a customer
is to show them
things at the end of
their customer journey
which will allow them to
have an amazing experience.
And you can now do that
using machine learning.
Because the way
we've employed it
is we get to know more
about our customer
based on their previous
orders and favorites
so that we can offer them things
in the last pages of checkout
which they wouldn't necessarily
think they could be offered.
For example, the page
that we offer is called,
have you run out of?
And that is a system where,
if I always, every third week,
buy dishwashing tablets,
and I get to that third week
where I've now
completed my basket
and the system has
recognized that I don't have
the dishwasher tablets,
it will prompt me
and it will say, well,
have you run out of this?
Do you expect to buy these?
That's an amazing service.
Because if I can add
that to my basket
without having to
see it not being
in my order and the frustration
that comes after that,
I'd be an extremely
happy customer.
So the benefit there
to the customer
is that they get to not be
inconvenienced by products
that they leave
out of their shop
because they've forgotten it.
So they're doing their
shop for a purpose.
And sometimes it's those
products that they leave out.
For the retailer, this
is massively beneficial
because the retailer gets
to build a bigger basket.
So it gets to make sure that
the customer is both happy
and the basket is
increasing in size
with those essential items.
And there, again, we use a
large extent of the Google Cloud
to build this machine
learning engine.
So that's really what I
wanted to cover today.
And I hope I've
answered your questions.
NICK MARTIN: I believe so.
Thank you, Jonty.
That's been-- well,
I'm sure you'll
agree with me-- a fantastic
insight into the Ocado business
model and also use of
technology and machine learning.
So a huge thank you.
JONTY ANGEL: Pleasure.
NICK MARTIN: Thank you,
everybody, for attending.
[APPLAUSE]
JONTY ANGEL: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]